there's big news in the investigation of
donald trump's handling of documents
marked as classified a federal judge a
trump appointee has granted the trump
legal team's request for an independent
review of the materials discovered at
mar-a-lago robert costa is following
this closely for us in washington bob
good morning how's the doj responding
good morning vlad this is a significant
new challenge for the justice department
because the probe is ongoing and this
could slow it down the department has
long argued that a special master is
unnecessary since it has its own team
already finished with its review of
evidence
in a 24-page ruling judge eileen cannon
a trump appointee granted the former
president's request for an outside
lawyer to step in writing that trump
faces unquantifiable potential harm if
more sensitive information is made
public the independent reviewer would be
directed to examine the documents
obtained during last month's fbi search
for any issues related to attorney
client or executive privilege the
special master and anyone else working
with the special master will have to
have the appropriate security clearance
that won't just be a top secret that
will be even higher levels mary mccord
was a former top official in the doj's
national security division they can't
just ship them by fedex or deliver them
to the special master's office these
will only be able to be reviewed in a
secured compartmentalized information
facility so this will probably involve
the special master going to the
department
or to the fbi cannon's order sets this
friday as the deadline for possible
candidates to be proposed who are
acceptable to both sides but the special
master doesn't have final say on what
the doj can and cannot use in a future
criminal case just because there's a
special master who might say oh this
document potentially raises executive
privilege issues does not mean that the
that the criminal investigative team
will never get to see those documents
that will just be the start of a process
of okay is there really a privilege here
and is that privilege overcome by
compelling interests the judge's order
also borrows the justice department from
further reviewing the evidence collected
until the special master's work is done
but it does allow for the continuation
of the classification review and
intelligence assessments being conducted
by the office of the director of
national intelligence over the weekend
trump continued to claim the search was
an abuse of power by the justice
department the shameful raid and
break-in of my home mar-a-lago
was a travesty of justice
what we are watching now is whether the
justice department will appeal the
judge's decision remember the
investigation has been moving along
delving not just into documents but into
possible obstruction by trump's team and
yesterday the department said it is
examining the opinion and will consider
appropriate next steps tony
all right bob thank you very much we've